so tell us what happened with your
friend in california well good to see
you guys you know uh have you heard
better ladies and gentlemen have you
heard that now get this work with me on
this
in california there's a problem where
there's homeless people have you heard
about this
yes it's out of control i think i read
it you know what else i heard about this
too you know why it's so bad in
california and this is this is very
serious is because other states
are giving their homeless population a
bus voucher
and a food voucher and a one-way ticket
to california so that's part of the
problem
too so i was i saw my friend in west
hollywood on saturday
and he was talking about the fact that
he had to get a new car and we were
going to introduce him to one of our
friends hey you know go see this guy
great guy he'll take care of you by the
way why do you need a new car
and it came up well my car started on
fire
so then i was thinking maybe he had a
defective car a lemon something bad
happened something weird an electrical
spark he's telling us this just by the
way
and this is now we were at a store um in
west hollywood on la cienega so this is
a very very you know you know the area
it's a very very popular area it's very
high traffic it's very uh busy during
the day
so he tells us that the reason he needs
a new car is because a homeless person
started his car
on fire there was a homeless or now
there's a lot of homeless people around
there right there on a homeless person
started his car on fire in the middle of
the day what's the motive what's the
rule
just because just because he was walking
down the street and tried to light the
light pole in front of their store on
fire but that was metal
so he wasn't able to do that so he took
the the uh
the lighter and he lit the car this is
not uncommon by the way
this type of thing is this middle east
or is this la
it's crazy and then he said he hates l.a
no
and when he's talking about that man
that's kind of crazy man i wonder what
that looked like the dude actually had a
video because the thing was on fire
you have a video of this yeah there's
actually video conferencing let's see
what we got this it looks like a movie
set
you got this
that's your friend's car i mean what is
that a range rover what is that
it was some sort of suv and that's la
cienega that looks like a porsche
the suv oh damn isn't that crazy
yeah that's in front of his store yeah
literally the stores right there by the
yellow and then that right down there
by the way right across the street
there's a you know one of the most
popular restaurants in la is a
restaurant called catch la
yeah you know the fish on melrose
they're opening up a catch steak right
there across the street but they can't
open
it because there's a homeless encampment
because there's one patch of grass
that is city property right public
property so then they
they sent up an encampment there so the
restaurant can't even open so
you know when i found out too that other
states cold-weather states are sending
people to california
and then no one even talks about doing
anything and slowly it gets worse and
worse and worse but that was just crazy
because it kind of hit close to home
knowing somebody that had his car
torched but he is going to get a new car
by the way
so so i got it by the way crazy story no
one
no one got hurt this kid nobody got hurt
which is good news it's a car a car
you can replace with insurance but
what's crazy is the fact that this is
happening right now regularly
in l.a and it's just part of the
lifestyle of living in l.a
what the homeless thing the burning the
cars the homelessness the looting that
can what are you gonna do what are you
gonna what are you gonna get from a
homeless person that has nothing go
ahead and sue him what are you gonna get
the state's gonna give you money the
city is gonna give you money they're
about to go bankrupt
so what are you really going to do to
this homeless person they're going to go
to jail
that's exactly what they want they want
a place to stay out with food and all
that other stuff hey let me light up
more cars to get a place to stay at so
i'm getting rewarded to lighting a car
on fire
you're giving me a place to live with
food and security
there is no safer place than prison go
to prison you got a bunch of security
people to protect you
and when i say there's no safer place
than prison you're in a place where you
the only people you have to worry about
is what inmates
sure so here we go let me light up the
car and i'm going to go to a place to
live and eat not so safe
yeah it is part of day-to-day life and
you almost become immune to it what you
see on a regular basis
you thought this was ten years ago you
you wouldn't believe that you were
actually living this life now you just
think okay what's next normal you just
continue to accept things it's normal
and by the way we talked about this last
week you weren't here with us we
the total number of homelessness in in
america today is around 100 580
000 total homeless people in america
today 580.
out of accounted for right yeah counted
for out of 580 guess how many live in
california sixty percent
160. okay not 160 percent but 160
000 of the 160 000 60s in la
and in the last 12 months it increased
by 20 000
homeless people just in the city of
unbelievable and it's all invisible
areas too it's not like they're tucked
away in the forest or in the woods or
yeah somewhere in a valley so i gotta
tell you something uh kai can you pull
up the tweet i got
from uh uh uh somebody that's running
for governor if you go to my twitter
account i told sam i don't know if sam
brought it up or
not go to my twitter account and just
type in patrickbet david go up there so
i get this tweet the other day
yeah click on that go down i retweet it
go down
yeah so not from the major so i get a
tweet uh
uh go a little bit lower go a little bit
lower maybe you should i thought i
retweeted it keep going
keep going keep going keep going keep
going keep going keep going it's that
far
down you got to be kidding me you got a
lot of tweeted man
is that the one go up i think that's the
one
uh camera's on the house says no that's
not the one anyways there was one tweet
that came out and i retweeted it
i'm surprised i can't find it anyways so
somebody
somebody shared the podcast remember the
podcast we did when i said the state of
california
needs to eliminate the state taxes and
the way you do it is what florida is
doing which is a tourist tax
yeah and california's got one of the
biggest amount of tourists that come in
every year and tourism is about
to increase how about you eliminate
state taxes and you impose a 15 percent
tourist tax for people that come so this
guy the video gets shared with them
wasn't he running for governor the video
gets shared with him apparently he is
running for governor let me see if i can
pull it i want to say his name is major
am i wrong on that i want to say
major uh will williams major
williams hang on let me just give him
credit because if he is
i want more people to look into here we
go i got it so kai
it goes two days ago it says someone
listened to the podcast
good it's literally two days ago so
chris quintin
shout out to him sends this to me and he
says a california governor candidate
major williams is adopting patrick by
david's message on how to solve
kai this is you can't see it it's on the
11th
april 11th right there you don't see it
go a little lower
it'd be great if we can pull it up
interesting is it
well maybe why don't you go all the way
to the top that shows the tweets and
retweets like replies yeah tweets and
replies right there see if it comes up
there
go up uh 10 hours ago it should come up
here in a minute
two days ago okay well then it's not
showing up on your end uh california
governor
candidate major williams is adopting the
patrick bay david's message on how to
solve california taxes eliminate state
income tax and impose a tourist tax
unfortunately california legislators
will vote for a tourist tax on top of
all the taxes including income tax
property
he put it on his website oh yeah we like
that i'd love to show this
kai i'm going to send this to you and
see if you can figure out a way to put
it up
uh because if this is the case i'd
encourage people to go look into him
uh yep it's time to think major for
governor
okay and he said economy taxes eliminate
state taxes
impose tourist tax of 15 this model is
viable and implemented by states such as
in florida our focus to make sure that
california family small business and
independent contractors are considered
for financial breaks
after disastrous year of misguided
decisions from the leadership of the
state
our administration will execute a
regulatory other than
so anyways there you go it's a great
idea i'll tell you why because if you
actively promote the fact that we want
more
right you're going to bring them in it's
going to only help the economy that much
more the tourists are going to come in
the hotels are going to come back the
restaurants the beaches are going to get
cleaned up it's going to be great
it makes i love the fact that you know
it was something specific you didn't
just say hey raise taxes here you say 15
he can easily go run the numbers do the
math on what that means based on
average tourism in california that might
even revive san francisco help the wine
country i mean all of california is a
tourism area i mean
of course and by the way here's what i
the point i made in the in the podcast
couple weeks ago when we talked about
this here's what i said
i said imagine a tourist is coming to
the state california
you want to go to san francisco napa you
want to go to san diego you want to go
to
hollywood palm springs pick it it does
you got a million places to go to
for vacation in california you think the
cli the customer that's coming out as a
tourist is going to say no i'm not going
the difference between spending ten
thousand dollars versus thousand five
hundred dollars hell no he's still going
to go
absolutely that's the point so what are
you doing i mean no one's like i'm not
gonna go to florida i'm not going to
south beach i'm not going to orlando yes
because of a tourist tax they're going
to pay it but the guy chris clinton
the the guy that said unfortunately
california legislators will vote
here's a tough part where states like
california anytime you
introduce a new tax they salivate over
it so if major williams if this is going
to be shared with you i want you to be
thinking about this and start talking
about it
if this makes sense to you is the
following
whenever you introduce a new tax what
they do is they sit there in the state
of california places like california new
york illinois they sit there and they
say
huh great idea but we're definitely not
going to eliminate
state taxes but guess what what if we
impose this
anyway five years from now 10 years from
now so you
introduce a good idea they run with it
to add it on top of everything else
so you could say why don't we add a gas
tax that's going to help
us eliminate state taxes and lower the
state taxes top line from what you got
from 13 points 13.3 let's just say with
obamacare all that stuff together
bring it down to six but rates let's
raise gas taxes
they'll say no let's do both of them so
you got to figure out a way to
get the voter to understand the
difference between the two yeah and you
know what they
they've already spent the money they see
that 15 they've always figured out a way
to say does your chair keep going down
guys we got to switch same thing as last
time okay and and you know so he's got
to get ready to figure out how to debate
caitlyn jenner over this because
she might be running for governor too
yeah it's going to be wide open in
california you know newsom is
pretty much fighting for his life right
now this recall thing is going to happen
now the difference is he's going to be
able to spend unlimited funds there's no
limit on what you can spend so he's
going to have 100 200 300 million
dollars in a war chest to fight this
thing
we'll see but practical makes sense we
need a couple alternatives
of people to look at here but but i will
tell you this shout out to a guy like
him
who's running for governor what this
shows that he's listening
it's the biggest thing that you're
listening to what voters
in the state that you and i both love i
may be in florida but i love the state i
lived there for 20 some years
i'd love to see that state get their act
together i will say this too real
quickly is i think people are going to
vote for their
with their pocketbook in this recall
election forget about
the environment forgetting about all the
social issues that are out there
everybody in california has been
affected by this so ignore any polls you
hear that newsom might be okay
that 66 percent of people want to keep
him in there no one's going to admit it
to a pollster
ever i think he's got a real chance of
getting out well so when is this recall
election in california this fall
it's happening boom i mean they haven't
announced it officially but they've got
the signature so you're voting for
caitlyn jenner over newsome
i got to hear what she has to say if she
runs i think it'd be interesting so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]